I live in New York I got a fresh haircut
New York fresh haircut before the show
before I left I said at the barber goes
somewhere between New Jersey wedding DJ
and department of homeland security I'll
be honest I think he nailed it he did a
great job so I want you guys to be
entertained but I want you to feel safe
saved these my priority up here as a
volunteer firefighter I see a lot of
things that are unsafe in society I see
this father walking around with a baby
and a pouch attached to the front of his
body which is so cocky that says look I
get women pregnant I make them have the
baby then I wear the baby as jewelry sir
please remove the baby that's not safe
I'm a volunteer firefighter you know he
says to be on the actual firefighter
want you get out of my face my baby
didn't hear what I said bro volunteer
firefighter that means I could do your
entire job in my spare time
and I stopped dropped and rolled my way
out of the conversation proving that I'm
a volunteer firefighter I fly a lot I
don't mind that there's a first class on
the plane I don't want to have to walk
through it to get to my seat cuz I sit
in zone three and when I walk through
first class I see a lot of things that
make me angry they have a lot of extra
legroom eating a five-course meal
drinking mimosas I'm not I'm not on the
plane yet that's disrespectful so I say
to each person as I walk through you're
not better than me you're not better
than me you're not better than me none
of you are better than me
I'll be sitting in the emergency row
where heroes live
[Applause]
[Music]
as I'm a volunteer firefighter
translation hero I'm also a Catholic I
believe okay I believe in the main
things when God I believe she respect
your parents I believe you should love
your neighbor the rest of it I don't
know flip a coin
should I not want to covet my neighbor's
wife probably not but maybe she
shouldn't be walking around half-naked
with the drapes open because that's how
sin happens that's how it happens it's
like her carelessness plus my
high-powered binoculars like I said I
live in New York I have a rodent problem
but that's the beauty of living in New
York you live in an urban area but you
still have the problems of a farmer I
don't tell my landlord I have rats why
not a snitch [ __ ] get stitches I buy
my own pesticides and I blast the rats
with I go to pop resurrection I blast
the rats with my own pesticides and I
believe it was Kelly Clarkson who once
said whatever doesn't kill you makes you
stronger
and that is especially true when it
comes to pesticides and rats because not
only do these rats not die they evolved
smarter more vengeful rats so I'm like
fine I go old school I set a trap put
cheese in the middle of it two hours
later I check the trap trap still set
cheese is gone my car keys are in the
middle of the trap they figured it out
the rats figured it out now it's a chess
match and I'm losing because I'm sick
from my own pesticides I can no longer
have children I probably could have a
kid would he'd be like a Benjamin
buttons probably an elderly baby that
ages in Reverse workout I go to the gym
here's the thing about the gym you can't
do the same workout because your muscles
are smart and they have memory and they
will memorize your workout then you will
not make any gains so you guys have to
do is muscle confusion you have to
confuse your muscles and that's what I
do I get dressed like I'm gonna work out
[Applause]
right before I step on the treadmill I
smoke a cigarette
muscle confusion muscles like I felt we
ready to go for a run only sorry muscles
were partying guy sees me smoking to the
jimmies like you can't smoke here it's a
violation of the fire code I'm like do
you know who you're talking to
I'm volunteer firefighter